this is what hacking looks like there
you go the NSA has the ability to track
any call you can make it didn't Edward
Snowden teach us that true very scary
is it possible to hack traffic lights
potentially causing havoc on the road
yes that's true
absolutely great to have a button they
could just do that right maybe they can
fix your morning community
security experts spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars to create the
equivalent of their own cell phone tower
to listen to and record cell phone
conversations sounds like a lot of money
yeah Oh what it is false
yeah so we're good no I was looking at
true and I got worried I knew that it
would be so cheap my person can access
over 96% of what is on the internet
through major search engines that's true
all right we don't want trainees be
right please be right even 96% here 4%
does add up to uh huh there's medical
devices like peacemakers can be had
right that's probably true because all
you need to do is get the frequency and
see Chopin Zuzu yeah they said they can
also hack an insulin pump good the
Republican National Committee's computer
systems were recently breached by
hackers with ties to the Russian
government I think that's true they're
publicly no no that's not true it
happened
happen because yeah they're shot and
they wouldn't mess with the Republicans
that was the Democrats that's right
that's false yeah Democratic National
Committee
good old not so dumb after well now
pretty clever
so the show premieres July 13th mr.
robot on USA 10:00 p.m. on Wednesdays
Julian no I don't know I should have
just kept o'clock under view to I was
checking me I was checking this photos
Wow